in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chip
and Chrissy are with us hey guys how are
ya doing great well I'll meet you
where are you guys from Carson Iowa long
lonesome highway east of Omaha there you
go
I like it sounds like a good song title
alright list the riff for a song there
you go
yes sir well good to have you guys
welcome honor to have you so you're here
to do your debt-free scream we are and
how much have you paid off we've paid
off $60,000 awesome and how long did
that take 11 months Wow and your range
of income during that time a hundred one
thousand two one hundred and five
thousand excellent what do y'all do for
a living I'm a training manager for a
multinational corporation and I'm a
professional school counselor awesome
yeah very cool well good to have you
guys so how much what kind of debt was
the 60,000 well we had a car and student
loan debt lots of student loan debt okay
how much was the car for those of you
looking deeply into your radio she just
pointed at him I think we know who the
student was okay alright and the car was
10 grand and the student loan debt was
alive D okay was 50 so what happened a
year ago that caused you to go on this
11 month journey a year ago we were
engaged and about to be married there
and knew we needed a plan that that we
could both buy into and stick to we had
a lot of dreams for our married life and
a few things we needed to pay off and I
am clearly the free spirit and ship is
clearly the nerd and yet you were the
one without any debt ironically yes
that's true okay so she was trying to I
turned me on to you Dave and she was
talking about your book and trying to
get me to listen to your CDs and Dave
this indeed I was like was this Dave
Ramsey guy now you know why is why whose
do you know him I was a little jealous
and then once I started listening to
you I couldn't stop and oh wow yeah it
was very cool and now I'm jealous that's
right it's a newlywed marriage what can
I say you guys are awesome that's fine
so your first big task of the new
marriage is attack $60,000 for the debt
it gave you a focal point for your first
year of marriage absolutely don't honey
yeah you don't VIN on that cuz you
didn't sell some stuff or didn't have
any money in the bank you've been on
beans and rice chicken noodle soup Dave
there we go very much every day for
lunch he has a 59 cent can of chicken
across - oh so it's not even good
chicken noodle oh it's that generic
stuff oh that's bad
well the good news is you don't have to
anymore if you eat like no one else
later you can eat like no one else
that's awesome very cool so you got
engaged and you're getting married a
year ago been married one year
approximately and you come home from the
honeymoon and you had already decided to
attack this stuff so I guess you sat
down then and did a budget or do you do
the budget at the time we did it right
after the honeymoon yeah every dollar
calm is fantastic oh good especially
here yeah very cool and so what was the
hardest part of this whole thing for the
two of you other than 59 stuff but not
as tough as what Chrissy's going to tell
you two days before we were slated to
have everything paid off I got in a
rollover car accident oh the car we had
paid off and honestly one of the first
things I thought after checking to make
sure I was alive was I just blew our
goal of becoming debt free on Friday
hanging upside down in the car
this is what you're thinking I'm not
proud
that truly was one of the first you
might be listening to too much Dave
Ramsey
I knew my back was hurting Wow oh my
gosh and so what happened then did you
have insurance on the car we we did have
insurance on the car and because we had
come so far financially it was no more
than a blip on the radar yeah and I
walked away with a few bumps and a few
speck does a man think you know we still
met are going on that Friday yeah the
cars today are so much safer than when
we were little kids I mean they really
it's ridiculous that you can roll the
car over and walk away with a couple of
bombs I mean it really that's awesome
that is good that's good news very cool
very lucky
yes well I'm blessed yes very good so uh
so you got the money from the car
insurance and that you bought another
car
it's out in the parking lot right now
you drove it down here yes sir all right
and that did that did you use a little
that to finish off the other dad or how
did it work out you said it was a blip
yeah we we did end up purchasing the car
and having a little bit left over to not
much but a little hi to our dad
we made our goal well problem Wow other
than a little bit of glass flying around
there right Wow Wow
well that's amazing so when people find
out that you paid off $60,000 in your
first year of marriage and they ask you
how did you do that what do you to tell
them the secret to getting out of debt
is I we made a game out of it really I
mean we had a we put you up on our
vision board at home every day we walked
by and looked at it and you know touched
it from time to time there's a big
picture of financial peace Plaza oh yeah
we had a we made a game on you know put
a happy face on the calendar every time
we paid off the debt you know
my my beautiful wife I was lucky enough
she somehow creatively had like I think
30 or 50 different things that you know
20 minute backup here and we put them in
the jar and every time we paid off
something we each drew from that so yeah
so it's a good fun we you know we we we
enjoyed paying believe it or not we
condition our minds to do that and now
we've got everything paid off for
miserable we need a new goal oh my god
that's amazing well congratulations you
you're fun that's I'm sorry about the
wreck and I'm glad it turned out okay
yeah that's good news very good news all
right it's Chip and Chrissy from Iowa
$60,000 made off in 11 months making 101
to 105 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream well done
well done you two great job great job
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind